So now we're ready for a quiz to see
if you understand the find command with the number as
the second parameter, as well as indexing and selecting
sub-sequences of strings. And the question is given any string
variables, so we're going to initialize the variable s to
hold any string. T to hold any string, and i
to hold any number, which of the expressions below is
equivalent to s.find passing in t as the target string
ni as the number? So here are the
choices, s index i colon, find t.
S.find t index colon i. S i colon.find
t Plus i or s, i colon, find t,
i colon. So check all the ones that are always the same as s
dot find t, i no matter what s, t, and i are. And for this
quiz, this is pretty tricky. Try to think
of the answer yourself before trying to run
anything into the Python interpreter. But feel free
to also run things in the Python interpreter
to try to confirm your answer and to see if things behave the way you expect.